[Music]
one personality do you have a
personality is a personal branding you
say something about you what's your need
you need to take on work and life
because we want to know next do you have
focus and this is really really
important of you going deep or are you
going wide because at the end of the day
we only remember the people who have
depth we talked about this before so
there it is again
next up is what is it that you do are
you being clear about what it is that
you do are you a basket leaver are you a
packaging master are you a branding
expert what do you do and do you
communicate that clearly and does the
body work support death last but not
least of course is the quality of the
work and on that we have a couple of
criteria do you nail the fundamentals of
design do you get the principles of
design correct are using the right
spacing the colors to communicate what
it is that you're doing and are your
mock-ups beautiful do you present the
work well do you have low pixelated
images or things that just don't look
good or poorly lit look amateurish and
even though you're exploring the work
are you showing us a to depth of
exploration we want to see that you take
an idea and you hit it out of the park
and you do everything that you can think
of and more hey everyone this is a
cut-down from a larger video that I
helped produce so do me a favor go ahead
and watch the video and let me know what
you guys think
or don't either way it's Joe